all the C words get tricky right  compliance  you know the hidden costs of compliance  in the work industry today is is  staggering what do you what do you mean  by that I mean that you know the cost of  hiring somebody is not simply the cost  of paying them their salary and on dirty  jobs certainly you you see I've talked  to so many employers in every state and  after we shoot usually over beer we  start to talk about you know the way  things really are what are the real  problems compliance is always a word and  that's compliance with a wide variety of  state and federal regulatory agencies or  without there are an army of angry  acronyms out there and they each have a  very specific agenda and I'm a I'm not  there's not a judgment call on OSHA or  the EPA or the SPCA or PETA but you know  they all have their letters and they all  have their marching orders and none of  them are there to make your life easier  they're there to make you more compliant  you